today's the day we end free covered
testing in england who could have
predicted it's the same day we've
recorded the highest number of
infections than at any other time in the
pandemic the latest ons infection survey
data finds an estimated 4.9 million
people in the uk had coveted last week
that's up more than half a million on
the week before it's worth mentioning
now
this data from the weekly sampling
project is now crucial as regular
testing data will all but disappear from
next week when testing stops and in
terms of infection levels it's a pretty
similar picture in all nations all very
high one in 13 people in england
infected with covid one in 14 in wales
one in 15 in northern ireland and one in
12 in scotland
look at the trending infections in
england in the last week with no
restrictions in place we clearly
exceeded the spring peak in infections
and they're now higher than at any time
previously and how long might that
continue well take a look at scotland
the ba2 subveriance of omicron really
took off their dwarfing previous levels
of infection it's not as a definitive
picture these bars on either side of the
dots show the statistical uncertainty
but there's certainly a hint scotland's
peak is passing
and there are very tensive hints the
rest of the uk could be approaching a
peak too look at positivity rates in
england that's the proportion of tests
done that come back positive and that
looks like it's falling an early sign
well what's all this mean well hospital
admissions are high the same as or
exceeding the january peak but look at
the coveted mortality rate it's still
way down on where we've been before
incredible when you think that one in 15
over 70s currently have covered it shows
just how good the vaccines are doing at
protecting us from severe disease
and with spring boosters now being
rolled out it's reasonable to expect
that that protection will continue